das ist ganz einfach du springst auf den
nächsten zug und fährt bis zur nächsten
haltestelle streng menschen echt gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend herzlich und solange
leute freut mich dass ihr wieder
eingestellt habe ich bin wieder am start
für euch mit einer neuen hilft mir folge
und auch in dieser neuen hilfen phase
geht es wieder um mein lieblingsthema
bei hilf mir und zwar mädchen gehängt
wir werden uns heute zusammen die folge
hauptsache in der geld koste es was es
wolle anschauen ich würde heute das
intro ausnahmsweise mal wirklich kurz
halten leute wie immer geht wenn ihr
einmal im monat einen 50 euro gutschein
gewinnen wollt seid immer unter den
ersten 20 kommentare man videos und
dicker das interessiert wirklich kurz
die sache ist ganz einfach du springst
auf den nächsten zug und fährt bis zur
nächsten haltestelle ist eine waffe
haben ist doch voll wird zu zeigen ist
okay so beginnt dieses video was hier
gezeigt wird ist scheinbar ein
aufnahmerituale wir sehen hier auf der
rechten die möglicherweise kandidaten
also diese birne möchte in der
mädchengang jetzt drin sein und die
mädchen-gang legt ihr dafür eine ganz
einfache aufgabe auf spring einfach mal
von einer 20 meter hohen drücke auf
allen fahrern zu zeigen ak bringt ja
warum
zwei sachen leute er ist die sache auch
bei dieser mädchengang ich habe schon
mal wieder über eine andere hälfte
mädchen gern gemacht geht die gleiche
regel und zwar dass man sich so
beschissen wie möglich einziehen muss
der rat meist das gleiche haben wir die
gleichen outfits verwendet warte mal ich
glaube in der letzten folge hatte auch
schon ein mädchen so t shirt an ki.ka
mentees 11 wie kann man sowas anziehen
alter und über zwei wirklich bestechende
logik von den bereits in der gang seinen
mitgliedern
sie legen ja einfach aus soja oder
wilson der gang seien dann springt von
dieser brücke und stirbt einfach durch
den stromschlag von der oberleitung
was dabei drauf geht echt zu alter als
ob dir der tod oder das leben wichtiger
ist als die mitgliedschaft in der hilton
der mädchengang und vorstellbar das geht
mir nicht in den kopf rein wie kann man
so etwas banales so was wert ist wie das
eigene leben über die mitgliedschaft in
dieser gang von wirklich absolut geil
angezogene menschen stellen unfassbar
leutkirch maß er ist nicht wirklich oder
also okay ich habe kurz nie nachgedacht
jetzt habe ich nachgedacht natürlich
passiert das nicht in der hilfen erfolge
weil das würde erfordern dass man dann
irgendwie einer stuntfrau hat oder so
die auf diesen zug aufspringt und das
würde erfordern dass man wirklich groß
mal plant und so ein dreh anlegt das
hilft mir natürlich nicht macht also
keine sorge also eine stelle mal drüber
reden dass der zug einfach so zehn meter
weiter rechts fährt also ich habe
unterschätzt dass mal die kamera so
bisschen weiter raus ist und die brücke
rente breit ist aber a steht sie noch
vom geländer von b wie soll das gehen
der zug für wirklich zehn meter weiter
rechts von ihr also auch nicht im spaß
auch nicht der hilfe folge erzählt dass
das rezessionsrisiko soder
aufnahmerituale in irgendeiner gang ist
weil dann nicht viele mitglieder
wenn man den scheiß überlebt dann nur
mit glück
[Musik]
wenn ich an der stelle aber nicht
korrekt von ihr dass sie sich nicht mehr
an ihre eigenen prinzipien hält kennt
ihr die sollte die wie man so
sprichwörtlich sagt wasser predigen aber
wein trinken so sie nämlich auch eine so
okay sie wurde nicht in die gänge
aufgenommen das ist schon ziel ist das
ist natürlich ein ernster fall aber so
ihr motto ist doch tief carmen takers 11
x 111
robert du hast ein problem das
katholische spürst emotionalen stress du
warst in der situation wo dachtest du
musst dein leben riskieren um bestätigen
zu anderen leuten aber ich werde jetzt
auch nicht mein leben für die risken
oder würdest du das machen ja das würde
ich gerne schon immer nicht also ich
wäre es nicht sein was ist dann das
machen sollten nicht sagen dass man von
bahnübergängen springen sollte erst
recht nicht auf fahrende züge um zwei in
der gruppe dazu gehört aber dein leben
hast jetzt nicht es gibt ja eben
[Musik]
walter vetter camaro junge wat is dat
für ein teil alter leute wie gesagt also
ihr wissen autos sind sensibler punkt
bei mir muss wirklich sagen in bis dato
habe ich sehr großen respekt für die
mädchen-gang gesagt klamotten verhalten
ist einfach alles top aber wenn ihr
jetzt irgendeinen scheiß mit diesem
camaro wir machen sollst das modell von
dem auto dann das kann ich nicht mehr
gut höchst ganze drum lunge könnte jetzt
nicht woanders machen was eben habe ich
gesehen dass irgendein auto dran war
wenn da auch nur ein kratzer ist dann
gibt es richtig ärger real-tor kalter
real tag ich sollte mich nicht so sehr
von diesen folgenden schildern lassen
aber nicht mehr vorstellen dass wir das
im echten leben passieren würde was ich
irgendwie kann ich irgendwie termin
kommt aus dem gebäude wieder raus hat
mein auto das ich mit meinem eigenen
geld bezahlt habe vor der tür geparkt
und dann komme ich raus und sie wie so
eine gang an voll brazen wirklich
brachten mit klamotten die aussehen die
aus dem new yorker 2007 wie die um ein
auto rum turnus anstalten machen
irgendwie die scheibe einzuschlagen da
aber richtig die hütte brennen ist
einfach noch abschauen
schaut euch doch mal an was willst du
eigentlich was soll der scheiß noch ein
falsches worten du kannst du was ich war
eine woche gilt dass man bitte eine
schlägerei alter oder willst mir bis
dato glaube ich hat mich schon mal eine
schlägerei bei helft mir also die
schauspieler die ema 50 euro pro tag
bekommen die kloppen sich natürlich wird
es nicht aber es wäre mal na ja das
haben wir oft zu sehen oder das
verhalten von sanitas und georgina ist
wirklich grenzüberschreitend sie
provozieren mit allen mitteln einen
streit um aufmerksamkeit zu erregen
aber so darüber nachdenkt so was haben
sie eigentlich gemacht also okay wir
sind eigentlich nur um dieses auto
herumgelaufen und haben in den
außenspiegeln geschaut klar als der typ
dann kam daran natürlich recht so das
ist natürlich nicht okay aber das
verhalten von samy und georgina und
alisha und komischer ist absolut
grenzüberschreitend man schaut nicht in
fremde außenspiegel
[Musik]
die nächste szene jetzt haben wir sie
leider auch verloren an den new yorker
2007 klamotten stil bis gerade eben sind
noch relativ normal aus und so ihr wisst
auch leute ich bin kein fan davon leute
wegen ihres klamotten steals pauschal zu
verurteilen
da wüsste ich sag jetzt ja nicht mal um
die zu dessen ich mache es zu meinem
eigenen schutz damit ich so was nicht
sehen muss
dazu gehören unfassbar ohne wird sollte
also das ist das was mich am meisten
aufregt im leben wenn leute geregelten
beruf nachgehen und einfach wirklich
geld verdient sie ihr eigenes geld
verdienen und nicht den tag damit
verbringen um sportwagen von fremden
männern herum zu schleichen und die
danach anzupacken dafür ist unter aller
sau ich will ich will so etwas nicht
fertig will das von keinem von euch
sehen so wehe einer von euch arbeitet du
bist nicht gerade in berlin wäre cool
wenn du einfach mal vom fernsehturm
ansprechen konnte was haben das haben
alle gemacht ja alle sind mit dem körper
vom fernsehturm gesprungen 350 meter und
wir leben noch und du denkst du kannst
es nicht machen
kein problem was soll ich machen ihnen
zusammen machen die landwirte in
ankurbeln das kann doch jeder also es
ist wirklich so teilweise leute muss ich
mich nicht mal mehr über darüber lustig
machen oder irgendwas übertreiben um
irgendwelche unstimmigkeiten dieser
folge aufzuzeigen
also da wo es in diesem typ dieser mann
hat einfach nur die mädels darauf
hingewiesen dass es nicht cool findet
wenn sie um sein auto herumlungern und
irgendwie keine ahnung da eine schmink
station dem außenspiegel machen also was
passiert am nächsten tag die neben
erstmal rache dafür alles klar
ok und was soll ich machen du sollst
seinen wagen clown fahrer mit weg macht
irgendwas damit interessiert mich nicht
ja was soll ich glaubte den wagenlenker
hat er überhaupt einen führerschein weiß
wie wird man ein auto an macht said mal
ganz davon abgesehen dieses auto wie
sagt das ist ein chevrolet camaro der
hat so schätzungsweise 400 450 ps also
krank viel power
selbst wenn sie den zu fahren bekommen
sollte hängt die drei minuten später im
baum damit
[Musik]
okay leute jetzt haben sie wirklich
nicht ganz überschritten jetzt sind sie
nicht nur um dieses auto herum getourt
und haben ihr geschminkt sessions da
gemacht sondern die blonde gut man weiß
zwar nicht wie so was nicht so weit sind
dass ich es gemacht hat aber sie haben
den camaro geklaut und sie ist damit
sogar gefahren
da hört der spaß für mich auch dazu kann
ich nur eine sache sein
also leute wenn ihr in eurer stadt vier
mädels mit neonfarbenen outfits aus dem
jahre 2003 herumlaufen seht dann
versteckt aber muscle cars checkt hier
ein vorgeschlagen dass wir die optimalen
kanal abonnieren das war natürlich
größere augen dank fürs zuschauen